Good morning everybody, thank you so much for joining me on this wonderful Monday chika. What are you doing?
You watching the door for me. Oh God everyone ignore the uh.
Everyone ignore the delivery McDonald's, that's actually extremely old
I I have no shame because yes, I ordered delivery McDonald's
But that's ancient also which reflects badly on me because I don't take my trash out anyway
So don't mind that this is not about this is this videos a cry for help, but it's not about that
I actually have a full music production
Sweet here stuff that I got going on and I need your help because I don't know what I'm doing
I've got my keyboard I've got my interface. I've got my computer with my software on it. I've got this
Which is broke and apparently what the hell is going on with that hang on the keyboard is meant to hook up with this
software set that
that allows you to
Switch instruments on the fly and do all this stuff
So what I need from you guys is help on learning this sort of stuff because as you know I've been practicing guitar,
I've been practicing singing
But one of the things that I want to actually do because it's another way that I can have a creative outlet
He's actually making music myself now. I don't have everything because I need my big audio monitors here. I don't have those yet
That's my next purchase that I got to buy
But those are on the way right now, but as it stands I have this software
And it's not like the best of the best. I think Pro Tools is the best but this is this Logic Pro?
Which is Apple's version of music production?
and
It's something that I want to learn just because I want to get started in some way so if you guys know anything about music
production
Let me know down in the comments below
Tweet at me some things that you've done if you've got a music channel on YouTube dedicated to making music
let me know in whatever way you can because I want to work with you like I I want to learn as much as I
Can because I can fiddle my way through this and I can get going on it?
And I will be getting going on it on my own but to be perfectly honest
I want help along the way, and I want help from you guys if you guys know what you're doing
Then you can help me and we can work together to try to make some
Honestly cool stuff because I'm no expert at piano, but with like you can make pretty much whatever you want
So that's pretty exciting to me in other news. This is going to be a very quick vlog
We are off to Europe in about a week
We are going to be going to a bunch of cities all across Europe if you go to toward markiplier calm
What's going on look at the devastation that chica has caused she has?
So many toys, she has spoiled rotten
But she just tears them all apart rips the faces off of each one kind of like
I'm not even joking about the ripping the faces off. She literally rips the faces off of her toys
And then for this one it's an especially heinous crime because she tore the guts out of this toy
She's a vicious horrible beast and likes to destroy everything that she shoes isn't that right chica boy?
That's absolutely right anyway. She's a good girl, but we're gonna be going on tour
If you haven't seen it for yourself go to tor
Markiplier comm check out where we're gonna be going and I'm really excited about this leg of the tour the show has gotten so good
Like tuned in dialed in we know exactly what we're doing
There's a lot of improv based in the show so every show is different
But we've gotten to this point where we've got a really good flow going if you haven't heard about the show either
I would recommend reading reviews because
There's no better way to tell about a show than reading what other people have said about it or hearing what other people have said
About it
It's been nothing but glowing
glowing reviews even people that don't know my channel that have gone to this show have enjoyed themselves just because it's really really fun and
I'm not just Tooting my own horn about it because it's I'm Tooting the horns of all my friends because
We go out on that stage together
and we rely on each other to try to be funny for you guys and try to be entertaining and
Each show that we do just shows how much like we've trained for this
We've worked for this
And how well we work together and how much you guys have fun at the show so if you've been to a show
let us know down in the comments what you think like what you've
Gotten out of it
What what to expect out of it like what kind of fun you had at the show and if you haven't gotten a ticket yet
Please do we're gonna be coming to Europe and it's going to be a lot of fun in other news
I've been getting in shaped like crazy
This is just minor like my life stuff, and I don't know how many people care about my life bullshit um
But I've been getting in shape as hard as I can
I've been doing insanity workouts, and I know this is just vapid
I'm not bragging about this because it's terrible and it hurts like hell, but I've been doing insanity workouts
I've been doing a strict keto diet. I've already lost like ten pounds in a week and a half
I am getting in the shape of my life for this
Tasteful nudes calendar, and I will not be shamed by it. I'm a man of my word even though
I set myself up for this. I'm a man of my word anyway all jokes aside
I've been getting in crazy shape and I've been dieting hard, and it's been really good. I feel good
I feel motivated I feel like I'm on track with my life. I feel like I'm settling into a schedule finally
I feel like I have time
To pursue the things that I want to pursue
Which is like this music production and video making and streaming like I've got everything in order
And then this tour is throwing a wrench in all of that
Because then I can't do this stuff right here because I've got it all nicely set up here
And I can't take it on the road with me, but all that aside. It's been so much fun
I've been able to pursue hobbies of mind that I haven't had been able to do in a while
I've been inspired to write because I've been reading so much crap. I've been reading books about the Warhammer 40k universe now
I don't know how many of you guys are fans of Warhammer 40k or Warhammer in general
So I started with the eisenhorn trilogy back in fall of last year and right now
I'm reading caiaphas Kain hero of the Imperium, and it's just
It's like goddamn delight, and it's so fun
I've read like 30 to 40 books in the middle of that throughout that time
And I've read pretty much every article on the Wikipedia about
Warhammer not the official Wikipedia entry, but their own wiki just detailing all the different things about the Warhammer 40k universe
And I'm just like my mind is blown because if I had soaked in this much knowledge about music production
That I would already be a savant at it, but I'm not because I'm not that obsess about it
But if you want to debate me on Warhammer 40k
It's been it's already been a great year like I've been getting in the shape of my life. I've been pursuing hobbies
I've got these new glasses that you guys seem to like I really like them my life is going great
I'm having a lot of fun so if you guys can help me out with this
It would be great help if you know about music production
Please let me know about it
let me know samples of what you've made and
also
If you want to see like series on YouTube and stuff like that because I have to record a lot of stuff before I leave
Like this next week is this going to be a recording slog of
Just getting as many videos I can for this next tour
So if you guys want series that you want to see just let me know down the comments below write down
Anything and everything chances, are I've already got it on a list, but there's no harm, and you guys are recommending what you can
so I'll be reading the comments very intently this particular video, so let me know whatever you got and
Thanks so much for watching and as always I will see you in the next video